[music playing]
CALE HUGHES:
Operationally, it works
just like a laser pointer.
There's a chamber inside
with special materials
that release photons.
INEZ KELLY: If you're
looking at a boat coming in
over the water, you can
target exactly the engine
and take out exactly the
engine, and not necessarily
damage anything else.
And that type of
precision weapon work
is something that
you don't really
get with conventional
weapons, because there tends
to be more collateral damage.
CHRIS WELLS: It's
useful against a variety
of threats, surface or air.
It's not a niche weapon
system like some other weapons
that we have throughout
the military,
where it's only good
against air contacts,
or it's only good
against surface targets.
[music playing]